David simple question first but it's the
most interesting one talk us through the
probabilities winner of the presidency
House Senate and talk us through the
likely permutations sure thank you for
having me
right now we have the presidency at
about 89% for Hillary Clinton and 11%
for Donald Trump obviously the Senate at
about 65 66 for the Democrats in the
house at about five or six percent for
the Democrats about 95 percent for the
Republicans a couple of key points there
we start with the presidency this is a
market-based forecast so it's using
futures contracts along with the polling
and other information and it's basically
assuming that Hillary Clinton is more
likely than Donald Trump to exceed
polling numbers right now Donald Trump
would have to exceed the polling numbers
by a decent amount in a couple of states
and for that to happen either the voters
need to be more like his voters or those
people who turn out to vote need to be
more supportive of him and early voting
does seem to indicate that Hillary
Clinton's get-out-the-vote advantage
more money more people on the streets is
working it seems unlikely that the voter
population is going to be more favorable
for Donald Trump than what we are
estimating from the polling and also it
seems that there's not much evidence for
shy Trump voters yet which is a good
indication for Clinton in the Senate
we're looking at literally a 50/50 split
is the most likely option which then
puts a lot of information on to who's
gonna win the presidency
David why is there such a major
difference between the polling and the
betting markets and the forecasting the
simple forecasting the betting markets
are able and to look at information
beyond the polling data they're able to
look at the get-out-the-vote operations
they're able to look at the early voting
and they're able to look at a lot of
these questions about how high will
Latinos go for Clinton how will these
shy chump voters turn out or not turn
out and it's really a question about
will there be polling error in her favor
or his
and they're looking at that and saying
right now no it's really likely that the
polling error will be in Clinton's favor
which will be a victory for the person
who's already ahead David if Hillary
Clinton wins but she loses both the
Senate and the house it's sort of Bill
Clinton revisited isn't it are we to
expect gridlock and politicking and all
sorts of goings on that in future years
well we do have markets for those as
well and obstructionism is what we're
looking at right now obviously this
question about whether or not the the
Republicans would allow any candidate
through for the Supreme Court is first
in a lot of people's minds as a
bellwether obstruction and right now
we're looking at if the Democrats do not
get 50 or more Senate seats with a
President Clinton there is a
non-negligible chance that they will
continue to obstruct the currently open
seat and any other future open seats and
so it's definitely something to be wary
of one of the really popular trades
right now whether it's a punter on the
street just taking your best or you know
a professional trader you know the
spread betting for example or the down
ballot races what are the really
interesting ones well look I mean so
people are following obviously the
top-line betting that's always a very
popular thing to do but there are
markets out there for all 51 states and
they're getting a lot of action
especially in Florida and North Carolina
in to an extent even in Michigan and
other states where where Trump has been
trying to push but also people are
trying to bet on the spread as you said
there's a lot of action on whether or
not Hillary Clinton will win by four or
more percentage points which seems to be
somewhere around the breakpoint at this
point for the national estimation and
you're also seeing all sorts of betting
about the ultimate makeup of the
Congress versus the presidency so to see
whether or not we're gonna have to
divide it of leadership or not